This video is sponsored by Blue Apron.
Hey wisecrack disembodied.
Jared here,
grab that potato chip because we're
talking about the animate phenomenon.
Death note while death note addresses a
range of philosophical topics spanning
from property rights to human nature.
One of the most interesting is justice.
What is it and how should it be applied?
Justice is hardly a new topic in media,
so why is death notes so special?
Well whereas most pop culture gives us a
cut and dry idea of justice.
Death note is unique not in what it says
about justice but how it goes about
saying it.
Woken was wise crack condition on the
philosophy of death note and even though
this show is 10 years old,
spoilers ahead.
Also a quick note about dubs vs subs.
Seems like no matter what we do,
we somehow do it wrong,
so we're just going to use the dubs on
this one because it's easier for us to
work with.
Hey,
that's more time for us to read and
write and make more episodes so please
don't hate us.
Death note follows light your gummy as
he discovers the death.
Note a notebook that can kill anyone by
writing their name minute and picturing
their face light.
A model student wants to use the death
note to create a world devoid of crime
soon after he adopts the public persona
of Kira,
the god of the new world.
He hopes to create of course anonymously
killing huge swaths of criminals,
places him in conflict with various law
enforcement agencies,
a mysterious detective name l and his
two successors and an m in death note.
We see multiple characters exploring
what is and isn't justice.
Let's just say the word comes up a lot.
I am justice,
justice,
but the cool thing is the show doesn't
give us a clear stance on what
constitutes justice,
but rather employs a unique method to
constantly challenge various definitions
of it.
An element of that method happens in how
individual characters propose their own
version of justice and first among these
is light himself.
It's hard to get a good sense of who
liked was prior to the death note.
Although we have some clues to his moral
compass,
it must be something wrong with me to
even consider it.
And his sense of moral obligation,
this world is rotting,
knows who are making it right,
deserve to die.
Someone has to do it.
So why not me?
Kira is an ends justify the means Kinda
guy.
Essentially the ends of being a crime
zapping uber tyrant justify pretty much
anything including shamelessly using his
girlfriend to distract the police and
maximize his kill.
Count
the Berlin and killed my parents.
To me,
Kathy hero
and killing people who aren't even
criminals who get in his way.
However,
once light renounces ownership with the
notebook,
I here by four fit ownership at this
he loses his memories of being Kira and
his personality changes noticeably as
does his sense of justice.
He goes from being a by any means
necessary kind of dude to a,
well,
maybe I shouldn't always be asshole kind
of dude.
This is shown by his refusal to even use
misses feelings in order to get
information.
To me exploiting another person's
feelings for personal gain is
unforgivable and I won't allow myself to
stoop that low.
This is a huge change from the guy who
pretends to love her for years just
because it was convenient for killing
people.
Light is even told by me so that she
doesn't mind being used for his cause.
I already told you I don't care even if
all you're doing here with me
think that would be enough.
But he always goes an extra step out of
the way to break his promises to her.
Here is a bit of a boy,
but light minus the notebook seems to
respect me.
So at least enough not to lead her on,
hey,
want to come sleep with me tonight?
What are you talking about?
Once he touches the death note again and
regains his memories and powers his Kira
Persona returns and he moves in with
Misa almost immediately to get even more
bonus killing power.
In other words,
treating people well is thrown out the
window for justice with a capital j.
There are countless examples of this
tension between light pre and post
notebook,
although they merge more and more toward
the end of the show.
One of the ways this is portrayed is
through lights,
conversations with himself or he
grapples with moral and practical
dilemmas.
Does that split personality sound
familiar?
Well,
Ross process but you were hosting both
death note and Lord of the rings are
likely to send in some an ancient Greek
story called the ring of guidelines.
Essentially a guy finds a ring that
makes him invisible and using this
anonymity he immediately bangs that
King's wife kills the king and takes
over whatever spooky Greek magic town he
lives in.
We could probably read this as an
allegory for the perils of Internet
comment sections,
but I digress.
In Plato's Republic,
this story raises a lot of questions
about the idea of justice.
The character glaucon who was actually
plato's real life big brother uses the
fable to argue that justice is just the
kind of social contract that keeps
people from hurting each other.
The thought experiment is meant to
demonstrate that people only really
value justice for its ability to make
them look good.
In other words,
it's only natural that someone within
visibility ring would go around acting
like an ass hat because people only
value justice or morality when their
actions can be scrutinized.
Sound familiar?
Humans will always try to maintain
appearances when they're in public.
That's just how we are,
but this is how they really feel.
Most are too afraid to support me as
they're worried about what others will
think.
Many would rather deny my existence,
but on the Internet where you can remain
anonymous,
support for Kita is growing.
As
soon as the risk of damaging your
reputation is gone.
So is all your interest in justice.
Glaucon goes on to say that it doesn't
matter if you were just or unjust before
putting on the ring.
The power will inevitably lead you to be
a bag of dicks and that's okay.
I can use the death note all I want and
I won't be punished according to
glaucon.
If you can secretly bang the queen and
still keep your reputation,
you will be way happier than someone who
cares about justice and banks.
Zero Queens.
And that's pretty much a light.
The boy Valedictorian who puts on a show
of normal morality even when he takes
joy in doing stuff that is probably way
worse than breaking the Royal Bro Code.
I never once felt cursed since I picked
up the death.
No,
in fact,
the thought never even crossed my mind.
I'm happier than I've ever been.
Oh,
thanks to this power,
I'm going to create a perfect world.
So why do Glau cons,
musings matter here?
Because one of the key questions death
note asks is what does justice mean when
nobody's looking?
This theme is repeated in light
pseudonymity as Kira in l n ends
nameless snus and in the anonymity of
the cure supporters later in the show.
And here's where the republic really
comes in handy as a socratic dialogue.
It's far less concerned with offering a
theory of justice than it is with
detailing.
The process of exploring justice in its
socrates and his frenemies use
hypothetical scenarios and varying
definitions to challenge what
constitutes justice.
Death note works in a similar way
showing the movement and evolution of
theories of justice between and within
the characters.
Many of the characters and death note
Misa lights and Mika me to name a few
believe that they possess true knowledge
of justice and the tension between these
characters and they're skeptics.
Draw out the real meat of the show in
one of the least subtle scenes,
both El enlight declare in unison,
I am,
I am.
Sentiment is repeated throughout the
series,
especially in the final episode or light
claims that by reducing violent crime
and ending wars he has become justice
itself.
Kinda has become law in the world.
We now live.
He's the one who's maintaining order.
I have become justice and hear.
Death note establishes itself as a kind
of modern socratic dialogue using
multiple participants to try and flesh
out some universal question like what is
justice?
I'll the republic from the minute light
proposes his vision of a new world.
In episode one,
I want the world to know of my existence
that there's someone out there passing
righteous judgment on the wicked.
The question of justice is brought into
play while he does struggle with himself
for a second,
might've passed judgment on others is
the first real challenger is rebuke
light sets out his plan to immediately
kill off the worst criminals while
letting the lesser ones dial,
and only then the world will start
moving in the right direction.
It'll be a new world free of injustice
and populated by people who I've judged
to be honest,
kind and hard working.
But if you did that,
it would make you the only one bad
person.
Rebuke is motivated by boredom rather
than any sense of moral duty,
but he notices the contradiction in
lights argument beginning the socratic
dialogue that lasts the rest of the
show.
There's no need to chronicle every
moment of this series long philosophical
inquiry,
but there are definitely some highlights
that show us the trajectory of this
conversation.
I've got a pretty good idea of what your
motivation might be and I can guess what
you hope to achieve.
However,
what you're doing right now is evil.
I'm evil.
I am justice.
If this wasn't clear enough,
this is where they end the episode by
yelling,
I am justice system.
Make sure we get it and did we get it?
Yup.
Right?
They both think they're justice.
Lights likes to refer to himself as a
martyr,
even if it means sacrificing my own mind
and soul,
it's worth it.
Which is pretty weird considering that
he spends years trying to make himself
the ruler of the entire world,
but if you subscribe to his Kwassa
utilitarian theory of justice that
killing criminals and making one person,
God will ensure peace and happiness for
the greatest number of people,
then he is sacrificing herself.
Knowing that becoming the god of the new
world will mean becoming more and more
Kira slowly killing light tiyaga me.
It also means that in exchange for
cleaning a rotten world,
he would have to contend with a rotten
self.
Something that he acknowledges he had a
probably knows that what he's doing is
evil,
but he'll try it.
Change the world even as a martyr at the
cost of his soul.
That's his brand of justice.
So this is lights,
conception of justice.
The world needs a Kira,
and since he was chosen,
he's willing to sacrifice himself in
order to make that happen.
His idea of justice is an old testament
style bloodbath.
We're sinners get punished,
and blasphemy is the biggest sin of all.
Did he mention the veritable monsoon of
biblical imagery in this show?
You know the churchy coral,
ah,
this
ode to Michelangelo's the creation of
Adam,
the apples everywhere,
l even washes lights feet since like
spends most of the show acting is Kira.
The distinction between the two may not
be terribly important,
but here it seems to represent lights,
ideal version of justice,
that the only true just world is one
without criminals achieved by whatever
means necessary.
However else speaking as lind l Taylor
highlights the contradictions in cure
his reasoning.
If a just world is one without
criminality than the criminal act of
killing people is also an injustice.
This resembles rebukes rebuttal in
episode one,
but the differences that rebuke stops at
the suggestion that light might be bad.
While l offers a competing example not
only as Kira unjust catching Kiera is
itself an act of justice.
The show stops short of telling us what
Elva leaves justice is in order to
believe that cure is violating it,
but that's kind of how socratic
dialogues work.
Poking holes and raising questions to
get closer to the truth here imagines
justice as a grand ideal.
A world without criminals.
L however only talks about justice as a
reaction to injustice.
A lot of characters believe in lights,
ideal justice,
but others seem to echo l philosopher
John Rawls,
much like a light and plato argues that
in order to correct injustices in
society,
we first need to have an idea of what is
roles and Plato disagree on a lot,
but they both support ideal theory that
when thinking about justice,
we should first try to understand what
it would look like in a perfect world
where everyone did exactly the right
thing.
This is justice under ideal conditions,
which for light and Mika me involve a
lot of people being dead.
However,
others like philosopher Naomi Zack favor
something called injustice theory.
This approach does not rely on a
preexisting ideal of justice and the
perfect just society,
but rather centers on identifying
injustices where they occur.
It's much more practical to point to a
case of injustice than it is to start
from a broadly applicable definition of
what is just by this measure.
Only after injustice has been
identified.
Can Justice be applied to correct it.
The L M N Alphabet soups hunt for Keira
doesn't seem to be directed by a belief
in a high in the sky definition of
justice,
but rather by the recognition that Kiros
new world is unjust.
Since we never get a clear sense of what
else concept of justice is,
it seems totally plausible that he sees
justice as the response to injustice,
so while light and those similar to him
favor a Rawlsian approach of a world
created around a perfect justice l is
more focused on correcting injustices as
they appear,
any definition of the just becomes
secondary.
The struggle and resulting dialogue
between these beliefs characterizes much
of the philosophical method in the show.
Although other characters like Metsuda
complicate the conversation and prevent
it from being a split between just two
ideas.
That being said,
we should briefly take a second look at
our cake.
Snuffing Sherlock Holmes,
his code of Justice is a bit more
ambiguous than lights,
although it's very ambiguity,
plays an important role.
In many cases it appears that l and n as
well as m are most interested in winning
a game of wits.
That game may be a symbolic battle
between competing moralities or it could
just be a case of some narcissistic
geniuses obsessed with puzzles.
Any of either case.
This lack of any strong convictions
about a positive meaning of justice
serves at least one critical purpose.
It means that El frequently plays the
role of inquisitor,
not so different from socrates in the
republic.
Another somewhat more surprising
inquisitor is Matt Suda who raises
sincere questions about the moral
judgments of light.
Kira,
the Japanese police l just about
everyone.
Even at the same time as he is mocked
for his inability to fall into line
early in the season,
he responds to El Speech on the childish
morality of Cura by pointing out that
violent crime in the area has decreased
since Kira began killing.
Well,
I'm not saying this to support to know
or to condone the murders,
but in the last few days throughout the
world,
but especially here in Japan,
we've observed the dramatic decrease in
the number of violent crimes committed.
He makes clear that he does not condone
cure his vision or actions,
but he's also skeptical of the hard line
taken by l.
Later in the series,
he has an exchange with the other
members of the task force that calls
into question the very foundation of the
squad,
the belief in the inherent evilness of
Kira.
Do you guys ever think that maybe cure
isn't completely evil?
What?
What kind of question is that?
Matsuda I've been thinking about it and
part of me just doesn't believe that he
is.
So now you think Kira has justice too?
I don't really know,
but I think the kid is trying to fight
evil and change the world in his own way
and well the world's become a good place
for people who live honest lives.
So
pseudo with all his self doubt is both
audience surrogate and philosophical
foil to the other characters.
Unlike light who is convinced of his own
project,
Lnn who are single mindedly obsessed
with the task of catching him chief
economy who is focused on finding the
true Kira to clear his son's name and
the rest of the task force who have all
staked their lives and beliefs on the
justice of ending Kiera once and for
all.
Matt Suda is constantly questioning the
values that are presented to him as
fact.
Hang on,
am I the only one who sees something
wrong?
He can go around accusing people of
being cute on,
but the fact that he's wearing a mask
says he's only trying to protect
himself,
not anyone else.
Matt suit.
His demeanor is very different than the
bravado of Plato's debate club boys.
But he first and foremost recognizes his
own ignorance
is,
I mean no way
crucial for revealing the ignorance of
those around him.
Even at the end,
as he kills light,
he does so with questions rather than
answers.
What was it all for the end.
But what about your dad?
What the hell did he die for?
Bye.
Forcing the viewers and other characters
to consider their own opinions of
Justice Metsuda helps organize a jumble
of competing ideas into a somewhat
intelligible conversation.
Matt Suda,
the modern socrates as 10 years of fan
forums demonstrate there's no real
consensus on who best represented
justice or whether lights new world
justified the means,
but that ambiguity is what makes the
show so poignant.
Death note isn't addicting,
detective procedural,
but it never abandons the original
question of what makes a just world.
And most importantly,
it never gives us an answer.
In episode 30 aptly named Justice Light
pretty much sums it up.
If kitty gets caught,
then that makes them evil.
But if he wins in rules the world and I
guess he's justice
by the end of the show,
Kira is defeated and ends brand of
justice seems to prevail,
but it leaves us with a feeling that
things might have been very different if
Kira had survived the warehouse rather
than giving us closure that l n n we're
innately more Justin,
Kira.
This idea of winner gets all morality
reveals at the war of competing moral
codes was kind of a logic game,
not a kind of truth seeking.
You could argue that this makes justice
totally meaningless for the world inside
the show end might be justice,
but for us the viewers,
it's not quite so clear cut in regards
to the meaning and implications of
justice.
Death note opens more doors.
It closes in terms of whether or not
socrates or rawls or Zach would find l
or Kira to be paragons of justice.
The short answer is definitely not.
Although there are some similarities
that we didn't address in this video,
like themes of tyranny and a focus on
what it means to be a just city.
The real connection between the justice
of the Republic and justice in death.
Note is not in their definitions but in
their method and that method
distinguishes death note as a show that
does philosophy rather than just
borrowing it.
Thanks for watching guys piece.
But before we go,
I want to share something with you guys
that I love as much as philosophical
anime and it's delicious free foods and
blue apron has got me covered on that.
If you're one of the first 150 wise
crack fans to sign up at the link in the
description below,
it can be your next favorite thing to
blue apron is offering three meals free
on your first order.
For the first 150 wives card fans who
sign up from this video,
just make sure you do it at the link in
the description below.
Blue Apron delivers farm fresh
ingredients that look and taste amazing
and while I still only have the cooking
skills of a college freshmen,
our team had no problem following the
easy directions with all the pre
measured ingredients to cook a crazy
good meal.
And as always,
Ryan had a lot of fun smelling it all.
And this month,
blue apron has more delicious meals on
top,
including sauteed shrimp and green beans
and the delicious meatball pizza,
wheat devoured.
Seriously,
guys,
it was good and so easy.
If you love food and want an easy way to
cook great meals at home,
check out blue apron.
They deliver fresh ingredients with
delicious recipes,
and it all comes in a refrigerated box.
So ingredients stay fresh,
even if you're not home when it arrives.
Shipping is always free and you can skip
or cancel service at any time.
So if you're looking to expand your
cooking repertoire and hate going to the
grocery store as much as I do or just
love the idea of fresh ingredients
delivered to your door,
check out blue apron at the link in the
description below.
And remember,
get your free food now,
the first hundred and 50 wisecrack fans
to sign up with that link.
Get three free meals on their first
order.
Thanks to blue apron for sponsoring this
video.
That's all for now.
I'm starting to get hungry again.
Surprise,
surprise,
thanks.
And don't forget to subscribe y'all.